all right we are now going to talk about
the nra convention which took place over
the weekend it took place not that far
in the same state of texas where the
shooting happened earlier the same week
in uvalde texas republican texas
governor greg abbott bailed on speaking
there some others bailed as well
understandably it looks absolutely
terrible to go and speak at the place
that celebrates more guns in more places
right after this horrifying mass
shooting that took place in uvalde but
ted cruz insisted on speaking and so did
donald trump one of the sickest and most
dangerous events i have ever seen we
covered it live ted cruz's speech was
downright sinister
with the exact type of pablum and
apologia that you would expect
in the wake of a horrible gun disaster
at a speech for an organization that
just wants more guns in more places
trump's speech was even worse and one of
the
most vile
uh stunts that i've ever seen at any
event is trump quite literally did a
gong show
trump decided to read the names of the
victims of the uvalde texas shooting
many of them
very difficult for trump to pronounce of
course any stunt based on trump reading
names is risky we know what what
happened when he tried to read uh indian
the names of indian people
in india very bad idea and they ring a
gong after each one look look at this
sick political stunt of silence as i
read the names of these beautiful people
all young
wonderful lives ahead of them
their brave teachers whose lives were
destroyed by
an out of control
lunatic
so we'll start look at this
alexandria
rubio
i thought the gong was a joke at first i
thought it was somehow added as a joke
in the feed
alitha
ramirez
ann marie
garza
annabelle guadalupe
rodriguez
eliana
cruz
taurus
ellie
garcia
jacqueline cazares
i'm not even going to subject you to the
entire thing
but this is i mean it's it's sinister
the way that this is being used and what
it reminded me of is there's this very
controversial thing that has happened
historically in the mormon church
where after certain non-mormons die
the mormon church will baptize them
posthumously
into
the church of latter-day saints against
their will these are people who had no
interest of in in being part of the
mormon church
and it's sort of like this they're part
of us they're being posthumously thrown
into the cult after their deaths
this is sort of like a version of that
it's it's to to to to pull these victims
in
um into the political cult of the nra of
guns of trumpism or whatever
it didn't get any better as the speech
continued trump talked about hardening
schools which is now the thing that
they're talking about
he ultimately called for teachers to be
armed he also made up the term virtue
cycling trump clearly wanting to read
the term virtue signaling i guess he's
not familiar with it and he incorrectly
reads off the teleprompter which obama
was evil for using remember obama used
the prompter and correctly read off of
it and it was bad trump has a prompter
messes it up constantly never an issue
listen to this
[Applause]
how many more tragedies will it take
until they agree to set aside their far
left political agenda and do what
is really needed and what actually works
this is not about virtue
cycling and signing this is about
blaming your enemies no we don't want to
do that this is about saving our
children's lives yes that's what we want
to do
surely we can all agree our school
should not be
the softest target our school should be
the single
hardest target in our country
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to believe anybody believes
this at this point why as part of a
comprehensive school safety plan it's
time to finally allow highly trained
teachers to safely and discreetly
concealed
carry
and we've talked before almost no
teachers actually want to do that and of
course it brings the added complexity
that if there's a shooter police show up
and they can't tell now there's multiple
people with guns shooting you think the
police are going to first stop and ask
questions excuse me who's the good guy
with the gun here so we we only shoot
the bad guy with the gun makes it
possible for imagine a student to even
uh overpower teachers and and take the
firearms it's absolutely and completely
bonkers um at another point trump
brought up a guy who i guess shot a
shooter in a church shot this guy shot
someone dead at some point and the guy
talks about how trump is actually still
his president
thank each and every one of you again
thank you president trump and you're
still my president
yeah
so as you can see there is this overlap
between
the maga cult
and uh
this this is a pastor so it's like
there's a there's an overlap a venn
diagram of christian nationalists the
mega election cult and the gun nra
people i mean that's very loud applause
for a supposedly nonpartisan
organization that's just about gun
rights to something that's insane you're
still my president just does it doesn't
make any sense and then lastly trump
capping off the speech
with dancing on the stage as music
played
he seemed to only do it a little bit
probably even trump realizing this might
look bad
if we have the second worst mass
shooting in the last 11 years since
sandy hook or 10 years and then i speak
at a pro-gun event talk about how great
guns are we certainly don't need to
restrict them
and then i dance after mispronouncing a
number of the names of the victims it
doesn't look particularly good
and maybe trump realizing that it's a
totally depraved and sick country and i
have never received so many emails from
people around the world with two main
emotions
uh
fear and just being horrified by what's
happening in the united states
but being simultaneously perplexed like
david what the hell is going on there's
another shooting
an 18 year old had assault rifles with 1
600 rounds of ammunition
and there's another shooting
and republicans say give more guns to
teachers and trump shows up at the nra
and he dances like it's it's
simultaneously being horrified and being
perplexed at what's going on
and uh
i i what can i say to them they're
completely right this is only happening
here the in this entire package this
configuration of this cult and the
availability of guns and the existence
of a party like the republican party
it's only happening here and it's
absolutely horrifying
sponsoring today's show is the new book
by jason murchie called wisdom a very
valuable virtue that cannot be bought
this is an excellent book i've been
reading through
no book can really teach you how to be
wise but this is a really well
researched nonfiction book that helps
readers
grow to love the pursuit of wisdom which
is really a process at the end of the
day and if you spend just two minutes
watching my show
you'll know america has a significant
lack of wisdom in many ways republicans
have made an art form out of failing to
think critically
they have their
flexible and exclusive values moral
dogmatism
right now is probably one of the low
points in this particular sense in
american history with trump tribalism
the pandemic and just the the lack of
wise thinking
the author of the book jason murchie
believes that while liberals ought to
aspire to be tolerant and compassionate
right-wing extremism and political
chicanery
must be resisted and overcome and mercy
really brings a refreshing array of
insightful and interesting quotations
and personal reflections it's a
deep and wide investigation into what
wisdom is
i've been really enjoying reading
through it it's
really easy to read in chunks
each chapter kind of stands on its own
so you can jump into the book very
quickly it's a book that could have a
really powerful impact on a lot of
readers pick up a copy at
davidpakman.com
wisdom
the link is down below